ROBERT MARTIN: So
I wanted to take
a quick survey of the room.
How many folks in the
room are game developers
that worked for a
studio or a publisher?
OK, awesome.
How many folks are thinking
about building their first game
and need to know more about how
to scale it up in the Cloud?
All right.
Great.
And how many folks are just
here because games are awesome?
Yes.
All right.
We're going to have a little
bit of fun this afternoon.
Obviously, this
is a great topic.
And we've got some cool
stuff to share with you.
So we're going to be talking
a lot about game servers.
But before we get
into game servers,
we're going to talk about Google
Cloud's mission for games.
So we're going to go a little
broader about what we're
focusing on for bringing
multiplayer games to life
in the Cloud.
Then we'll get
into game servers.
What are they?
And why do I need
them for a game?
What are the metrics that matter
for running game servers well,
particularly in the Cloud?
And then, how do we
scale game servers up
for global audiences?
How do we build really massive
games with game servers?
And then, if you
were at GDC, you
might have noticed an
interesting announcement
we made there.
We're going to talk a little
bit about the future of gaming
in the Cloud at the
end of this talk.
So we're very passionate
about games at Google.
We have a lot of ways to
work with game developers,
with game players,
and with creators.
We're passionate about helping
you create, connect, and scale
your games in a lot
of different ways
across many different channels.
Today we're going to focus on
two of those logos, the second
and the third from the left.
We're going to talk
about Google Cloud
for running your game servers
and your back end services.
And we're also going to talk
a little bit about Stadia.
So Google Cloud's
mission for games--
so as it turns out, building
and scaling a global multiplayer
game has quite a bit of
complexity involved in it.
And if there's two things
that Google is really good at,
it's scaling things
up really big--
we currently have
eight services that
have a billion users
in them each, daily.
So Google really
focuses on scaling.
And we also focus on
reducing complexity.
The reason that services like
Gmail and YouTube and Docs
became so popular
is because we were
able to take the complexity
out of using those services.
So we want to bring that
same sensibility to games.
We want to scale
games up really big.
And we want to make it as easy
as possible for you to do that.
So we have four pillars
that we believe will
help us deliver on our mission.
Number one, cross platform.
Cross platform and cross play
have become really important
concepts recently with games.
Players want to be
able to enjoy a game
on a device of their choosing.
Game servers are a
critical component
in delivering cross platform
and cross play experiences.
Google is a leader
in open source.
So with Kubernetes, we
established a de facto
open standard for interacting
with infrastructure
in the Cloud.
Kubernetes is your
open source API
to compute and storage
running in any cloud,
or in your own data centers.
We want to bring that
same sensibility to games.
So for any of the games
services that we're building,
we're going to go open source
because we believe you should
be able to run them anywhere.
This is in stark contrast
to the gaming services
that you might find
in other clouds, which
tend to be proprietary, and
involve a degree of lock in.
So Google also has a lot of
expertise in machine learning
and analytics.
And we're very excited about
bringing our capabilities
to bear for games in
this space as well.
And I think that first
slide that we looked at
does a really nice job of
discussing that One Google
story.
We have a lot of different
ways to help build and publish
amazing games.
And we're going to explore
One Google a little bit more
when we talk about GCP
and Stadia later on.
So what is our Cloud
for Games team building?
We're focusing on
three different areas.
The first is game
server hosting.
We're focused on making
our compute platform
the best and most
high performance place
to run your games.
This is going to be the
focus of our talk today.
But to run a large
multiplayer game,
you also need platform services.
You need a place
to run your APIs,
so that your users can log in
and get assigned to a match.
So we're doing work there.
And we're also bringing
the scale of our analytics
and machine learning
solutions to gaming as well.
So we're going to focus mostly
on game servers for today.
But we're working in all
three of those areas.
So this is our reference
architecture for games.
So most games have a
fairly similar flow when
it's a multiplayer experience.
So a gamer starts by
logging into their profile,
loading up their attributes,
their skill level,
other items that will be
used later on in their play
experience.
That's step one.
That's a platform
service API call.
Step two, once I'm
signed in, I need
to find some friends
to play a game with.
That's called matchmaking.
So I make a call to
a matchmaker service.
I get assigned to a match
with a bunch of my friends.
And next up, we
need to play a game.
We need to get
assigned into a match.
So the third step
in the process is
that this group of people
who've been assigned together
into a match get assigned
to a game server.
And then finally, as
we're interacting together
in that game, lots
of interesting events
are being generated.
So we want to capture those
events in a data warehouse,
so that you can analyze
what your players are doing,
think about how to improve
the customer experience,
and how to monetize your
game most effectively.
So in today's talk, we're
going to focus mostly
on this part of the
equation-- the game servers.
So let's start by defining
what game servers are so
that we have a common
language for discussion.
So what are game servers?
And why do I need them
for my multiplayer game?
So we'll start with
the definition,
and then we'll dig in
a little bit deeper.
But a game server is
the authoritative source
of events for your game.
A game server broadcasts that
state to all of the clients
so that they can visualize an
accurate representation of what
that player should be seeing.
The game server also
captures and processes
all of the inputs
from your player.
And the game server
needs to do this
on a very consistent and
timely manner in order
to provide a smooth and fluid
experience to your players.
So let's use an example,
one of my favorite games,
Apex Legends.
Who loves Apex Legends?
Awesome.
Let's use Apex
Legends as an example.
So to understand what
a game server does,
we need to also understand
what a game client does,
and how the client
and the server
interact with one another.
So on the left hand side,
you can see a picture
of what a game client does.
So let's take a match
of Apex Legends.
60 players, battle
royale format.
You have 60 game clients,
one for each player.
They're going to be running
on a PC, or a console,
or for some games, they might
be running on a mobile device.
The responsibility
of a game client
is to render the graphical
experience that that player is
experiencing.
Graphics, sound, and input are
the primary responsibilities
of the client.
Because this is a graphically
intensive workload,
this is where your
GPU comes into play.
So a game client is
heavily reliant on a GPU
to get its job done.
So if graphics are what
a game client focuses on
for one player, then what
does a game server do?
Well game server is
running in a data center
on a host or a virtual machine.
That's the first difference.
All of the players that got
assigned into that match--
all 60 players--
their game clients are going
to connect to that game server.
The game server, contrary
to what you might believe,
doesn't process graphics at all.
The game server is responsible
for the state of that game
world.
And because the game
server is dealing
with data rather
than graphics, this
is a CPU intensive process.
You don't typically have a
GPU involved in a game server
at all.
So an analogy that I
like to use is, a game
server for this island
that 60 players are
dropping onto,
the game server is
sort of penciling in the
details of that world,
and drawing out a blueprint.
And then that
blueprint is sent out
to the game clients where a high
fidelity graphic representation
of what that player
sees is rendered,
based on that blueprint that's
generated by the server.
So let's talk a little
bit more specifically
about what game servers do.
Game servers have to receive
the input from the players.
Based on that
input, game servers
are going to track the positions
of those players on the map.
Those game players are going
to interact with obstacles.
They're going to
run into buildings.
They might even run
into each other.
The game server is going
to process what's happening
when those objects collide.
We have physics like gravity.
In combat games, you're going
to have particles flying around.
So the game server is
calculating velocities and hits
or misses.
And so once all those
calculations are performed,
the game server is broadcasting
the results back out
to those game clients so that
they can render the results.
And this has to happen very
consistently, up to 120 times
a second in very
high fidelity games.
So let's go back to our
example of Apex Legends.
And let's talk through
what's actually
happening as we're playing
through that game of Apex.
So these battle royale games
all start in about the same way.
You've got a big island, an
airship passes over the island,
and those 60 players
begin to skydive one
by one onto that island, falling
at terminal velocity, 160
miles an hour to their preferred
destinations on that map.
The game server is
calculating the positions
of all those players as
they're falling to the ground.
Now those players are
adjusting their body position,
which changes wind
resistance, velocity,
trajectory, acceleration.
All of these things are being
recalculated in real time
by that game server.
So next, those players
land on the island.
They begin picking up loot.
They begin picking up
items, weapons, preparing
for the battle ahead.
The game server is keeping track
of each player's inventory,
and the position of
objects on the island.
Players start going upstairs,
entering buildings, running
into walls.
Now we're doing
collision detection.
And once all the
players have equipped
themselves sufficiently,
the combat begins.
Projectiles start flying around.
Hits and misses are calculated.
If we have explosive
projectiles,
we have particles that
are being generated.
All of this is being
calculated by the game server.
And at the beginning
of the match,
we start with 60 players.
And as the match goes on,
we get down to one player--
the ultimate victor in the game.
And so what you might realize
is that at the beginning
of the match, there's
a whole lot of work
that game server has to do
to calculate all 60 players'
inputs and positions.
At the end of the game,
there's a lot less work to do.
But regardless of that
changing workload,
the game server has to
maintain a constant tick
rate throughout the match.
So you might say, OK, I've
been playing multiplayer games
for a while.
What do we need
game servers for?
We used to have this
thing called peer-to-peer.
And a peer-to-peer
model, let's say
we've got a few PCs that
have been assigned to a match
together, and we just
elect one of them
to also take on the
role of the game server.
So that PC will become
not only the game client,
but also the game server.
Well, so there are a few
problems with this approach.
Number one, your PCs are
located on a home network,
and there's lots of variables
out in that environment.
How do we pick which
one of these PCs
should become the server?
Should we pick the
highest clock speed?
Should we pick the lowest
latency or the best bandwidth?
Let's say that we go with
the best network connection.
Now after the match
starts, let's say
someone else in that house
starts streaming a 4K video.
Or let's say that
someone in that house
starts downloading a huge file
on a peer-to-peer network.
All of a sudden, the network
characteristics of that PC
have fundamentally changed.
Let's talk about scale.
Today's battle royale games
have 50, 60, 100 players.
A few network connections
into a consumer network,
that scales just fine.
Let's try 100 connections
into a PC on a home network.
It doesn't scale.
And finally, and probably
the most significant issue
is that-- remember,
we said that server
needs to be authoritative.
So if that binary is
deployed onto someone's PC,
they can hack that binary.
They can mess with the
authoritative nature
of that game server.
All of the traffic from
all of those players
is coming into that
person's home network.
They can interfere
with that traffic
to change the balance of
the game in their own favor.
So peer-to-peer was great
when we got started.
But for the types of high
fidelity experiences people
want today, we've
outgrown peer-to-peer.
So how are dedicated
servers different?
We've got one
additional component
that we bring into play, which
is that we deploy that game
server into a virtual machine
in a professional data center.
What does this do for us?
It brings us
additional consistency.
Now my network is being
managed by professionals.
It's being monitored by SREs.
I don't have the kinds of issues
that I have on a home network.
I have high speed
network interconnects
on these virtual machines,
so I can scale up
to more connections
per game server.
And most important of all,
that binary is firewalled.
In a professional
environment, it's much harder
to interfere with that binary
and with the network traffic
going into that data center.
So now we're ready for a world
class multiplayer experience.
OK, so we understand
what game servers are
and why we need them to deliver
world class experiences.
What matters for game servers?
We need to understand
this to be able to deliver
the type of services that
high fidelity games demand.
Performance matters.
And there's two key
metrics for a game server.
The first is latency.
This is a network metric.
So if we have game clients
that are communicating
multiple times per
second with that server
and need to receive replies
back multiple times per second,
we need the lowest
possible network latency
between those clients
and that server.
So that's our network benchmark.
And then if we're running
on our game server
in a tight loop that's
processing all of those events
that I told you about for up
to 100 players in a match,
our CPU needs to be able to
process that loop consistently.
So we call that frame time.
So that's our CPU
performance metric.
We're going to dig into both
of these a little bit more,
because these are
really important.
So let's talk latency.
What kind of latency do we
need for a real time game?
Generally speaking, for a real
time game like an Apex Legends,
you're going to want about 25
milliseconds round trip time
to your clients or less.
That's preferred.
Some games you might be able to
get away with higher latency--
50 milliseconds, maybe
100 milliseconds.
It's going to
depend on the game.
But for the types of
games we're talking about,
25 milliseconds or
less is preferred.
So let's look at a map
of the United States.
Let's say that we're running
our game server on one coast,
and we're running a
client on another coast.
You've got at least 50
milliseconds, typically,
between those two endpoints.
So we've already doubled
our latency goal.
That's not going to work.
Well if I'm looking at this
map, and I'm familiar with GCP,
I might say, you know,
those little blue flags--
those are Google data centers.
I'm going to be
clever, and I'm going
to put all my game servers in
that one right in the middle.
Well, networks are funny things.
You might expect the
latency to cut in half.
But it's not always a
function just of distance.
It can be
carrier-based, and there
can be other concerns like the
number of hops between the two
endpoints.
So deploying all of your game
servers on a continental basis,
generally, is not
going to hit the mark.
So you're typically
going to end up
with something that
looks like this, where
you deploy collections
of game servers
to several different
data centers,
and then you assign players
in a radius around those data
centers to the closest
possible deployment.
There's a bit of an art to this.
Because as you
shrink those circles,
you start decreasing
the number of people
that can play a game together.
So if you shrink those
circles too small,
your matchmaking pool
becomes too small,
and people can't find
other players to play with.
But if it gets too big,
your latency is too high.
So there's a bit of an art to
balancing those two things.
And helping you figure out
how to deploy your game
servers based on your
audience is something
that we can help with.
So that's latency.
Now let's talk about our
CPU benchmark-- frame rates
and budgets.
Now again, imagine
in a simplified model
of a game server
that you just have
a while loop that's running.
And all of those things
that I told you about
are a line item in
that while loop.
You're going to want to go
through each tick of that while
loop in exactly the same amount
of time every single frame.
So we call it a tick rate.
Sometimes it's also
called a frame rate.
And so for a battle royale
game, a typical tick rate
might be 20 to 30
ticks per second--
20 to 30 Hz.
So that's exactly the
frequency that you want
to iterate through that loop.
So if you have a
tick rate of 20 Hz,
you've got about 50
milliseconds to make it
through a single pass of
that game server's main loop.
50 milliseconds may
sound like a lot of time.
But let's take into
consideration how many players
we've got in that match.
We have 60 players.
So per player, I
have less than one
millisecond to get
through that main loop.
One to two milliseconds is
a big deal on a game server.
So there's not a lot
of room for variance.
And we'll talk more about
variance in a little bit.
So let's zoom in on what's
happening during those frames.
This is two frames being
processed on a game server.
We're going with
that 20 Hz tick rate.
We have 50 milliseconds to
get through a single frame.
In this example, we're
actually able to get
all of our work done
in 40 milliseconds.
That's great.
We got done early.
But remember, we have to
wake up for the next frame
right on the boundary
of 50 milliseconds.
So we're going to go to
sleep for 10 milliseconds.
Then we wake up and start
processing the next frame.
This is what we want to see
frame after frame after frame.
We finish within budget,
and maybe a little bit
leftover to account
for variance.
This is what we
don't want to see.
So in this example, still
50 millisecond frame budget,
it took me 60 milliseconds
to process that frame.
Now I'm into the next frame.
What am I going to do here?
I'm going to have to
drop that second frame.
So all of my clients
are not going
to receive an update
for that frame.
So let's think about what
this looks like over time.
The top scenario is
what we want to see.
We want to see every single one
of those frames consistently
processed.
Because when this happens,
all of our players
are going to have a very fluid,
very consistent experience.
That game is going to
flow just like a movie
that they're watching.
That's what we want.
In the bottom example,
we're dropping frames
pretty frequently.
What that's going to result in
is what we call rubber banding,
stuttering.
You're going to see
skipping around in the game.
And after maybe a
few minutes of that,
you're going to have some
very unhappy players that are
going to start logging tickets.
Not good.
So let's be a little
bit more specific.
What do we mean when
we say "consistent?"
For most games, we want
to process those frames
within budget, at least 95%
of the time, if not higher.
So we need a very, very
high level of consistency
and a very low
level of variance.
So one of the
things that I'm very
excited to talk about today
is our compute platform.
Clouds are busy places.
Running a game in the cloud
is very different than running
a game on a bare metal server.
We have a hypervisor
on that cloud,
scheduling resources that has
overhead associated with it.
And you have other tenants
that are running processes
on that same host.
They may be running
game servers also.
Those two things can
introduce significant variance
into the performance that you're
encountering on a game server.
So up until today, we've had
one type of virtual machine.
If you've used GCP, you're
very familiar with N1
standard virtual machines.
They're really cool.
We abstract all of the
underlying hardware away.
And what that means
is, I can go in there
and dial in exactly how many
VCPUs use I want from 1 to 96.
I can dial in exactly
how much RAM I want.
Very customizable,
very flexible.
But in order to accomplish
that, very abstracted
from the underlying hardware.
Also, our N1
standards on Skylake,
which is our newest generation
of hardware up until today,
runs at 2.7 GHz.
That's our sustained clock
speed across all cores.
So today, we're introducing an
entirely new hardware platform
called Compute Optimized VMs.
And these are going to
bump the clock speed
up significantly to 3.8 GHz.
And that's sustained
across all cores.
And we've also got
some features in there
that are going to reduce
the variance that you're
going to see even at
that high clock speed.
So let's dig in a little bit.
So compared to our
Skylakes running on N1s,
you're going to see a 40%
increase in performance
on our Compute Optimized VMs.
What does that mean?
Conceptually, that processing
time in your main loop
decreased by 40%.
You get a lot more
room for error.
You can also do a lot
more within that same 50
milliseconds.
We've also increased
the speed of the network
up to 32 gigabits per second.
Now I can think about connecting
more players to my game server
because I've got
more clock cycles,
and I've got more
throughput on the network.
So that's high performance.
Let's talk about variance.
So I've illustrated
a physical host here.
This is a conceptual version
of what a host in the Cloud
looks like.
We have very large CPUs,
typically more than one socket
running on a host.
Those sockets are connected
with an interconnect,
and they each have
a local RAM bus.
In an N1 standard, that's
all abstracted away from you.
You just have a big bucket of
cores and a big bucket of RAM.
Let's say that you're running
a game on the CPU on the left,
and some of your RAM has been
scheduled onto the RAM bank
for the other socket.
I'm going to have to reach
across that interconnect
to access my RAM,
which is going to be
a lot slower than if I were to
access that same RAM locally.
And I don't have any
visibility or control
into that on a standard VM.
In a lot of cases, that's
still fine for your game.
But for cases that are very
sensitive to performance,
with our Compute
Optimized VMs, we're
exposing the underlying
hardware platform,
which is Cascade Lake.
So now you'll be able
to have transparency
into the physical hardware
that's running on the host.
And we're also
exposing this topology.
So now you have visibility into
the NUMA topology of the host.
So it gives you a
lot more control
over the workload
that you're running.
We also do some cool things
like pinning your RAM
to the local socket.
So if you run the
right size shape,
you can effectively
capture that socket,
and your RAM will be pinned
to that local RAM node.
So some really cool
stuff for gaming
with Compute Optimized VMs.
Those go into alpha today.
I've got my contact
information on the last slide.
And if you're interested
in starting to test them,
reach out to me, and I'll
help you get that set up.
All right, let's talk
about scaling up.
So now that we know it's
needed to run a game server,
we want to run a whole
lot of game servers.
So how do we scale a game
server up for global audiences?
So in the picture of
the United States,
you saw a few
different GCP regions.
Globally, we have 19 regions.
We have four more coming.
That'll be 23 regions.
So those are different
locations that you
can place your virtual
machines as close as
possible to the gamers that
will be connecting to them.
So this picture might look
like a lot like the picture
that you see from other clouds.
All clouds have regions.
We all have zones.
One of the fundamental
differences between our Cloud
and other clouds is
that all of our regions
and all of our edge pops
are connected together
with our private fiber
optic interconnect.
So in other clouds, when you're
transiting between data centers
or between edge
pops, you're going
to be transiting the internet.
So you're subject to the network
topology of the internet.
With Google Cloud, when you're
transiting between data centers
and from pop to data center,
it's all on our private fiber.
So I mentioned, we
have 19 regions.
That's a pretty nice
selection of locations
to deploy your servers.
If you look a little
closer on this diagram,
there's all these gray dots.
Those are our edge
pop locations.
We have 134 edge pop locations,
all with fiber interconnects
back to our data centers.
Game servers use public IPs.
That's how our game
clients out on the internet
connect to them.
When I spin up a
virtual machine in GCP,
that public IP is globally
advertised at all 134
of those edge pops.
So when your client goes to
connect to the region that's
closest to him,
he's actually going
to connect to the edge
pop that's even closer.
And then he's going to transit
the fiber into our data center.
So this is how we're
going to get you
as close as possible
to your gamers,
and give you the lowest possible
latency into those locations.
OK, so let's talk about scaling.
Now that we understand we have
a global private fiber optic
network to run our
games on only with GCP,
let's think about
how we're going
to scale up on that network.
And we've got three
different options.
I mentioned earlier that
Google is all about open.
We love choice.
So we have three different
ways that you can run your game
servers in our Cloud.
You can build the scaling
infrastructure yourself,
and some of you have already.
We have an awesome
managed partner
that you can work with to help
you run your game servers.
And you can look into using
Kubernetes and containers,
and leveraging the power
of Kubernetes to scale.
Let's talk about
these three options.
So let's start with
building it ourselves.
So let's say that we want
to deploy our game server
into three different zones.
We're going to use the
basic fundamental building
blocks of Google Cloud.
We're going to use
virtual machines
and the APIs
associated with them.
And to scale the collection of
virtual machines up and down,
we're going to use managed
instance groups, which
will create new virtual
machines for us very easily.
So in each zone, we'll
have a collection of VMs,
and a managed instance
group to scale up and down.
So that's the GCP infrastructure
that we're going to use.
We're also going to need some
additional infrastructure
that we're going
to have to build.
It's typically called a server
manager or an autoscaler.
And that piece of
software is going
to be responsible
for calling out
to the appropriate managed
instance groups and VMs
and scaling them up and down.
Well that sounds pretty easy.
I don't have to
depend on anyone else.
This actually turns out to
be a pretty complex piece
of software to write.
And in order to understand
why it's complex,
we need to look at how
game servers are deployed.
But generally
speaking, we're going
to recommend this option for
those that have already written
this piece of software for their
own bare metal environments,
for another cloud,
and simply would
need to retrofit it to
use our managed instance
groups and VMs.
So let's look at what
game servers look
like when they're deployed.
Do we just spin up
a whole bunch of VMs
for each one of
these game servers?
Typically not.
A game server is a pretty
lightweight process.
It's typically single threaded.
For that reason, it
typically only needs
a single core, maybe two cores.
And so there's too much
overhead in spinning up
a virtual machine for one VCPU.
So what's commonly done,
even on bare metal,
is you bring up a larger
host, and then you
bin pack a bunch of
processes onto that host,
utilizing however many
cores your particular game
server needs.
So in this example, I've got
an N1 standard 16, 16 VCPUs,
and I've got about 16 game
server processes running
on that single virtual machine.
So when you're thinking about
scaling up and scaling down,
you're not only spinning
up virtual machines,
but you have to worry
about all that bin packing.
You have to think about how
to drain that host as matches
come to a close.
So there's a lot
of lifecycle that
needs to be built into
your server manager, not
to mention error handling.
But for shops that have
built their own logic,
this can be a great route to go.
We're actually very excited
that the Division 2 is running
with this methodology on GCP.
So that game launched
on GCP very recently.
We're very excited that they're
running at scale in our Cloud
using this methodology.
And what Massive really loved
about working with Google
is that we understand games.
We're gamers.
We love digging in and helping
companies scale their games up
in our Cloud.
So that's the build
it yourself model.
And you can scale
games way up if you're
willing to invest in
that infrastructure.
Let's talk about the
managed partner option.
Maybe you don't want
to invest all that time
in building your own
scaling infrastructure.
And instead, you'd
prefer to enlist
the expertise of a partner who's
a professional, running game
servers, who can provide
24/7 365 service, who
can run your game servers,
not only in Cloud, but also
in a collection of bare metal
colos located globally--
a partner who has 20
years of experience
running game servers.
We're very excited to work
with Multiplay as our game
server hosting partner.
And they can provide
a managed partner
level of service to you.
And we're even more excited to
talk about Apex Legends, which
uses the multiplayer
service on GCP to scale up
for a global audience.
Some of these numbers
are pretty incredible.
So Apex Legends scaled up to a
million players in eight hours.
Think about that for a minute.
That number seems incredible.
But then think about
the fact that it
scaled up to 10 million
players in three days,
and then multiplied
that number by five
and scaled up to 50 million
players in only four weeks.
This is exactly
the kind of outcome
that you want for your game.
And this is why you would work
with a partner like Multiplay,
and run your game on a
global cloud, like GCP.
If you read any of the press
around the Apex Legends launch,
it was really positive about
how smooth the experience was
for the players.
This game just went from zero
to millions without a hitch.
And that's because of that
combination of Multiplay
and GCP scalability.
This is a very
exciting use case.
So then let's talk about the
third option for scaling game
servers.
The third option is leveraging
the power of Kubernetes.
So when you think back to that
diagram that I drew earlier,
a virtual machine with
a bunch of processes bin
packed onto it.
That sounds an awful lot
like a Kubernetes node
with a bunch of containers
bin packed onto it.
Kubernetes is really,
really good at doing that.
However, Kubernetes is doesn't
understand game servers.
Kubernetes is designed
for stateless workloads.
It's designed for
HTTP workloads.
So we built an
extension to Kubernetes
is called Agones with
Ubisoft that teaches
Kubernetes about game servers.
It teaches Kubernetes is
how to handle UDP endpoints.
It teaches Kubernetes
about game server
lifecycle so that
Kubernetes is doesn't
decide to scale down
your game servers
in the middle of a match.
So with Agones, we're
building an open API
to run and scale your
games with Kubernetes
in an environment
of your choosing.
And in the same way that we
approached Kubernetes and GKE,
we're working on a
managed service for Agones
as well that we'd love
to talk to you about.
So we're excited that
Supersolid has chosen to launch
their new game, Snake Rivals.
This will be the first
production game on Agones.
And we're just thrilled to have
this game launching on Agones.
We're working with many other
studios on non-production games
for Agones.
So you have these three
different choices,
and you can choose
which of these
is the best fit for your
team and for your game.
And in any of
these three, you're
going to know that you've
got Google's infrastructure
powering your game
behind the scenes.
So let's talk about the
future of cloud gaming--
this thing called Stadia.
So our client and
server discussion
will come in handy here.
Stadia is a new kind
of gaming platform.
It brings high
fidelity AAA games
to any screen that
can run Chrome.
It does that by moving that
game client that we talked about
earlier with its
GPU into the Cloud,
rendering the content
in a Cloud Data Center,
and then streaming
that content as if it
was a video to a Chrome screen.
So in a sense, if we've moved
the game server into the Cloud
with GCP, we've moved the
game client into the Cloud
with Stadia.
So let's talk about what that
private fiber optic network
does for us with Stadia.
10 to 25 milliseconds
to our clients
sounded pretty good
without Stadia.
Now our clients are running on
the same fiber optic network
that our servers are running on.
So think about what that
does to your average latency
to your clients, and what kinds
of possibilities that opens up
for new types of games, and
new types of interactions that
haven't been possible
when your game's clients
were distributed
on the internet.
Now we mentioned
that Google is open.
You can still run your
game servers in a colo
or in another cloud, and
it'll work with Stadia.
But you're going to be
back to that old latency
model, where you're transiting
the internet 10 to 25
milliseconds.
So we're really excited
about the new types of games
that people will build when the
entire game infrastructure is
on the same private
fiber optic network.
So here is a bit more
of a detailed view
of what the architecture
would look like.
So the only thing that's
out on the internet now
is your Chrome device.
Your game client has
been moved into one
of those edge pops that I showed
earlier in our network diagram.
So it's even closer
to your players
than the game server is.
But it's communicating
with your game
servers over that private
fiber that you saw earlier.
Here's the same picture.
If you're running your game
servers and another cloud
or in a colo, you're still
going to get great performance,
but you're not going to get
that same level of low latency
that you're going to
get with everything
running on the same network.
So what do Stadia
and GCP do together?
Security.
All of your network traffic
now is on a private fiber
optic network, except for
the streaming data going back
to your clients.
Performance we've
already talked about.
Let's talk a little
bit about egress.
One of the significant costs
of running game servers
can be egress.
If I'm sending updates to
hundreds of players tens
or hundreds of times a second,
that generates a lot of egress.
You have to pay for
egress in the Cloud.
When your egress is
going from GCP to Stadia,
we've worked out a significant
discount on the egress.
So it'll be actually
less expensive
to run your game servers
on GCP if they're
interacting with Stadia.
So we're really excited
about this combination.
We're excited about
the new types of games
that you'll build.
And we're very excited
to work with you to scale
those games up in the Cloud.
So we'd love your
feedback on the session.
My contact information is
at the bottom of the screen.
Feel free to email
me or reach out
to me on Twitter or LinkedIn.
If you're interested in
those Compute Optimized VMs,
let me know.
I'll help you get whitelisted.
We think they're going
to be pretty awesome.
We've gotten some early feedback
from a major AAA studio.
And they're very, very
excited about the performance
that they're seeing in
their early testing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]